[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world in
pop culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather Bruce and a my Anna Wade and
this is your news for Monday February
5th now we've been gone for a couple
weeks and some things have happened that
we kind of just wanted to briefly touch
on first of all we are still waiting for
that Han Solo trailer that I thought was
coming out earlier but apparently not
unless of course it drops at the Super
Bowl which sorry this was recorded
before the Super Bowl
sorry Wow we also got a sneak peak this
week Oh captain Marvel's new costume
looks a little Green Lantern II so I'm
excited to see where they're going with
it because I'm assuming this isn't her
final form oh we also heard that art
princess Carrie Fisher won a Grammy for
Best spoken word album for her
performance on her audio book of The
Princess Diaries finally getting the
respect she deserves
that's rates apparently to uh dundies
getting a sequel about his American son
which I definitely thought was a joke
but it's realist so looking forward to
putting all the Australian actors ever
to work her a lot of cameos another
thing that I thought was a joke at first
is Nintendo has the labo which is a
cardboard extension for the switch and I
was a little worried about it at first
but having read more about it it
actually looks super cool they're using
the switch censors and some pretty
unique in awesome ways that I didn't
think we're possible to do with the
switch and one of them is a robot right
now I don't know what could be more
geared to me and my interest than
Nintendo making a robot that you can
wear and then play a video game on it's
like the perfect thing okay Jack for me
and I can't wait to try it out the other
one is a toy extensions that can do
things like make some
soare piano which still looks really
cool saw the car and the more the more
fishing ride yeah yeah it looks like it
might be really interesting Nintendo
also this week announced that we are
getting a Mario Kart app which I am very
excited about because it seems like a
great platform for Mario Kart especially
if you can play with your friends or
even use some of the motion sensors
further there's something like that also
lately Nintendo has been doing really
well with their apps
Super Mario run I didn't really play
that much but I am pretty addicted to
Animal Crossing pocket campus so you
know I was always addicted to animal
present so that was going to be
guaranteed so like I would play at all
cost Nintendo also this week has
confirmed that they are in fact making a
Mario movie with illumination studios
which in case you don't know that's the
minions Despicable Me Studio so I think
it could be good it's got to be better
than the last Mario movie we got you
know which one I'm talking about
we don't need to speak about anything
any further so maybe there might be some
minion crossover unless the goombas are
like the minions or something like that
we'll see yeah well tricity
um also this week we heard about a new
Superman prequel and no it's not the
Krypton show on Sci Fi no no no no it's
a whole different one called metropolis
and it's coming to the DC streaming
service now to be perfectly honest it
doesn't sound like a great idea to me
part of the reason is that this was
originally supposed to be a companion
show to Gotham on Fox and it was kind of
stuck in development at Fox for a very
long time before DC finally decided to
just pick it up and put it on their
streaming service so this is the fourth
confirmed show that we have for the DC
streaming service which has also still
not been named or has a positive release
date on that yet either so I'm a little
worried about this project it's supposed
to follow Lois Lane and Lex Luthor as
they explore Metropolis and kind of
learn about the seedy underbelly of
that's lurking below and tropi list
that sounds very Lex Luthor II I don't
know where where they're going with this
but we'll see also how old's will Lois
Lane be in there right I have no idea a
child no oh no not it's we'll see I'm
not too confident in this project
especially to y'all know how we feel
about Gotham I know I'm sorry go ahead
but maybe you say it won't be because
they've just taken the original idea and
like it's ended on it so maybe it's not
in that kind of realm anymore I don't
know we'll just have to wait and see
because that doesn't even come out until
2019 and there's been no casting news or
anything about it they've just announced
that it's coming it's here and I guess
in the loop otherwise this week we saw a
bunch of trailers we might have seen
more during the Superbowl again we
recorded before the Super Bowl so there
might be some trailers that we're
missing
who let us know in the comment down
below I'm sure you already did otherwise
the trailers we did get to see this week
starting with disobedience which looks
super dramatic and super cool it is
Rachel theis who has been exiled from
our religious community and comes back
after her father's death to rekindle the
flame and some relationships with Rachel
McAdams it looks super hot and steamy
and very dramatic honestly this looks
like a really interesting story to see
how they cover it in such a small
tight-knit community that has their own
feelings on your sexuality whether or
not it's homosexuality or
heterosexuality because there's a moment
when she goes in for a hug and he like
you know kind of yeah you're not
supposed to touch me it's really
interesting how in that community they
are kind of viewed yeah it looks really
interesting to be honest though I did
not click on this video right away cuz I
totally thought it was clickbait okay
sure sure
that's range of I see a way to make
Adams incanting sure
okay well it's real it is real we can
look for it in theaters on April 27 also
this week we saw a trailer for mute
which is super futuristic and super
action-packed
it looks really cool starring Alex
skarsgrd and Paul Rudd and it looks
kind of like a combination like a cross
between Blade Runner and John wick
mm-hmm what a great combo right some of
the visuals are not very inspired by
Blade Runner but if you're into that
kind of futuristic almost cyberpunk look
to it this might be for you yeah might
be for you
and I like the concept of having the
lead character mutes he's just not
saying anything I think that's super
cool and just letting his actions speak
louder than words what that's right you
can look for that on Netflix on February
23rd so not too long yeah yeah yeah also
this week that's right the trailer we've
been waiting for for a while
ant-man and the wasp trailer dropped
this week with Paul Rudd and Evangeline
Lily's suit as the loss looks amazing
it's got wings and blasters sorry about
that
ant-man sorry someone not trusted that's
right it's true Paul Rudd still looks
hilarious in this and I liked a lot of
the action shots and sequences that were
included in the trailer and I'm sure we
have tons more to come but it looks
super cool yeah some really interesting
ways of even just that knife fight of
running across the blade what's really
cool concept although I have a lot of
questions about that building that
shrinks down it's like a a rollaway
suitcase like I just someone built that
someone note that I don't know how
whoever was the architect of this was
like oh yeah it's totally normal to have
giant wheels be the foundation of an
office building also pillars are
retractable right great
totally looking at the blueprints you
got it was done by probably under
patient what a lot of money do not ask
questions about had a few crews to cycle
through you know yeah I did like the
ending to the trailer as well with the
Hello Kitty PEZ dispenser yeah you know
expanded it'll be the new Thomas the
tank
I'm really looking forward to a man''s
loss and I'm sure we have a lot more
little sneak peeks and trailers to come
but this one has satiated my appetite
for now for now because we have to wait
until July 6 to see it yeah well I'm
sure there's plenty that we must let us
know in the comments down below what you
would like us to talk about next week
otherwise you can find me on Facebook as
I on away tour everywhere else as
awesome I honor how there were few
people is get in touch with you you can
find me on Twitter at Heather ruse
Instagram at a truce or twitch twitch TV
slash Heather roofs and that's pretty
much as it from us here I'm hoping a
certain someone turns up in time for top
5 tomorrow otherwise like we're gonna
have to host it
what so tune in tomorrow to see what
happens there otherwise in the meantime
bemis up
[Applause]
you